public sénat en partenariat avec l' afp
les échos radio classique présente
[Musique]
[Applaudissements]
invité ce soir de l'épreuve de vérité
bruno retailleau le président du groupe
est républicain ici au sénat et le
président de la région les pays de la
loire
bonsoir mont saint michel grossiord et
merci d'être avec nous pour ce rendez
vous le public sénat avec l' agence
france presse avec les échos et radio
classique et vous répondrez à trois
questions que viendront vous posez
jean-francis pécresse mickaël szames s
et deborah clos d'abord comment
jugez-vous le calendrier des mesures
fiscales qui donc va s'étirer en fait
sur tout le quinquennat puisque le
premier ministre l'a dit à la france sur
le plan budgétaire est dans les cordes
deuxième question est ce que le sénat va
faire office de contre pouvoir
emmanuel macron et à son gouvernement
enfin comment la droite votre parti
doit-il se reconstruire entre attitude
constructive et critique est d'abord une
toute première question
[Musique]
1h15 de discours efficacité confiance
courage conquête ce sont les mots
fétiches du premier ministre aujourd'hui
est ce qu'il a réussi selon vous sur la
forme puisque on va entrer vraiment dans
le détail ensuite son grand oral
moi je les trouvais alors attention
puisque c'était gérard collomb qui
prononçait le discours dont parle pas eu
nous au sénat en direct le premier
ministre mais encore une fois une heure
trente de discours c'est trop en deux
jours rml mâcon qui nous affligent et un
discours qui était très très long là à
nouveau plus d'une heure plusieurs
ennemis de discours en tout cas au sénat
et le régime est un peu plus lent alors
manifeste que j'enregistre la bouche du
ministre de l'intérieur je trouvais en
tout cas que il y avait une distorsion
entre ces mots là le courage c'est à
dire une forme de volonté en marche si
j'ose dire et la route qu'on ne voyait
pas bien c'est à dire que on s'en tient
des objectifs parfois généraux mais on
voit pas comment on y parvient c'est le
cas par exemple de la dépense publique
mais j'imagine qu'on entend va en parler
mais a quand même edouard philippe a
réussi à exister aujourd'hui on avait
dit qu'il avait dissout phagocyté par le
président de la république non oui mais
c'est ce que je combatte à un démenti à
tout ce qui a pu être dit ces derniers
jours
c'est ce que je ne comprends pas si le
positionnement du président de
république et du premier ministre
pourquoi parce que hier prétendent
république c'est un peu enfermé dans son
propre piège en voulant s'exprimer avant
le premier ministre il sait condamnée à
être très générale trop général parfois
lyrique on aime on n'aime pas j'aime
bien à respirer intellectuellement
oui oui mais il ya certaines parties que
j'ai que j'ai apprécié franchement on
peut le faire mais une heure et demie
c'est très bon de trop général trop
générale sauf sur les institutions mais
très franchement ça n'est pas ce
qu'attendent les français en général et
l'heure est aujourd'hui aux journées aux
règles également non encore assez
générales c'est dire qu'on attend du
premier ministre quand il dit par
exemple la france a une addiction à la
dépense publique
ou en tout cas l'état il va falloir nous
désintoxiquer
on attend de savoir comment ova se
désintoxiquer on écoute et on a une
litanie de dépenses supplémentaires
que ce soit sur le fameux service
militaire d'un mois il va coûter
notre commission des finances de la
défense et des affaires étrangères a
mesuré le poids cette charge financière
ça sera 30 milliards 50 milliards donc
d'investissement donc il ya d'un côté la
proclamation d'objectifs mais de l'autre
on ne voit pas les moyens pour y
parvenir on va reprendre sa dans le
détail mais vous le connaissez edouard
philippe même s'il n'a jamais des filles
liste parce qu'il n'a jamais été fignolé
connaissez ma alors je connais vous avez
aujourd'hui j'ai donnant à temps tout
d'abord ces termes-là sarkozy juppé ici
à nice c'est du passé c'est du passé et
franchement j'ai aussi des amis super
puissant sarkozy vous avez vu
aujourd'hui en soit le ministre de
droite
mais peu importe
en tout cas dans dans le discours il ya
cette volonté effectivement et et on
sent notamment à travers la dépense
publique
on sent une volonté d'apurer les comptes
de l'autre quand même y aussi des
annonces sur la fiscalité décalé par
contre la csg on va taper les retraités
tout de suite oui alors les français qui
roulent au diesel doivent s'attendre
très avec la convergence de la fiscalité
la convergence de la fiscalité sur les
sauf moi je le traduis les français
n'ont peut-être pas compris ça veut dire
que quand vous allez faire un plein de
60 euros à 65 euros
vous allez en prendre dont 10 ou 15
euros supplémentaires encore une
question à propos du président de la
république parce qu'il est aujourd'hui à
brest pour un filtre pour une plongée à
bord d'un sous marin nucléaire donc le
jour du discours de politique générale
est-ce que ça est ce que ça vous
surprend est ce que c'était le jour
we must have de l'état russe a
franchement ça me choque pas le chef de
l'état est en même temps chef des armées
et qu'il ait s'embarquer à l'île longue
je crois donc dans le finistère sur un
sous-marin valeurs je trouve ça plutôt
bien enfin jeu en tout cas j'ai pas de
critiques apportées l'accord il veut de
son emploi du temps si vous
vous étiez des députés auriez vous voté
pour rentrer je leur ai pas postées
je rêverais vous auriez voté contre je
pense que j'aurais voté contre
je reste cependant voté compte dans la
mesure où je n'ai pas été convaincu je
reste sur ma faim comme beaucoup de mes
collègues d'ailleurs
d'ailleurs vous savez il n'a pas été
très applaudi il a été applaudi à
l'assemblée on sait pourquoi puisque
monsieur castaner et monsieur ferrand
avait recommandé au groupe en marche des
maillets le discours c'est libération
qui le dit bar à sion est pas forcément
un journal opposé fondamentalement est
systématiquement monsieur macron avait
demandé pendant on est mal
on est mal de temps en temps par des
applaudissements le discours du premier
du premier ministre qui avait manqué
hier ce qui avait peut-être manqué hier
bon gars il était très solennelle mais
on est à versailles c'est le congrès
alors je me sens très allants pour
commenter les mesures fiscales annoncées
aujourd'hui premier ministre
pas seulement elles sont nombreux il y
en a d'autres il ya des mesures en
matière d'éducation de santé de
fiscalité donc surtout bon quand même à
en parler tout de suite avec jean
francis pécresse le directeur de la
rédaction de radio classique qui nous
rejoint
[Musique]
bonsoir en français soir michel bonsoir
bruno retailleau alors on parlera
évidemment dans ces agences différentes
mesures fiscales qui ont été annoncées
par edouard philippe mais avant comment
est-ce que vous jugez ce calendrier
fiscal puisque plusieurs plusieurs
baisses d'impôts ont été différées sur
les prochaines années
tellement classique d'abord ce que je
veux dire c'est que il ya quand même un
clastres à saintes il s'est assez
classique classique voilà il faut
utiliser un épithète vraiment ya un
contraste entre d'un côté le
réquisitoire qu'elle s'est livré le
premier ministre aujourd'hui le
président de la république hier
puisqu'il a qualifié les années hollande
d'immobilisme et aujourd'hui le
réquisitoire que le premier ministre a
fait c'était quoi c'était de dire que
c'était n'importe quoi sur le plan des
comptes c'est donc tous ces gens là ont
accompagné monsieur hollande quand même
monsieur collomb par exemple qui
prononçait le discours ici à voter tous
les têtes et les budgets bien
donc nous on connaissait puisque le
sénat on était beaucoup critiqué par
certains médias je me souviens il ya
huit mois
quand nous avions refusé parce que nous
le trouvions à ça sert de voter la
deuxième partie du butin
donc première chose le constat in ils ne
découvrent pas ils font mine de le
découvrir
ensuite alors je vous dis accélérant
pour la cour des comptes entre temps
quand je vous disais que c'était clair
non mais le rapport du sénat au dessus
ya huit mois
il transite absolument notre rapporteur
général albéric de montgolfier avait
fait ce constat
maintenant ce dont vous me parlez c'est
tellement usuels c'est à dire que on va
avoir le matraquage de la cg tout de
suite la fiscalité écologique très
rapidement en même temps pour les
français
et évidemment par exemple là où on est
très handicapée la fiscalité sur le
capital
la fameuse flat tax on va augmenter la
fiscalité sur le capital puisque
l'augmentation de la csg va se traduire
sur un alourdissement de la ressource
qui permet aux entreprises d'investir et
l'investissement de demain ou
d'aujourd'hui c'est toujours l'emploi de
demain ou après demain
donc si vous voulez de ce côté là il ya
une grande déception
et cette déception ne peut pas être mis
sur le contre qu'il ne savait pas où en
étais budgétaire il le savait et
d'ailleurs si vous les rectifier
vraiment
cette trajectoire il ferait un collectif
budgétaire
ils ne le font pas ils citent au fond le
retour de la vieille politique c'est ce
que vous êtes en train de vous dire
c'est la politique à l'ancienne
je trouve que c'est la politique à
l'ancienne exactement ça a été le
réflexe de tant de gouvernements de
temps vous fermez différé quand même
certaines certaines baisses d'impôts
comme la baisse de l'impôt sur la
fortune ou la transformation veut dire
que ça sera vrai sens donnant du
monsieur en baisse de charge est ce que
voilà est-ce que c'est raisonnable ou
est ce que c'est un enterrement en fait
non si vous voulez gelé le d'hier moi je
pense j'ai pris au mot le président de
république en citant les trois
révolutions le mot révolution est en
réalité le titre du livre qu'il a écrit
pour sa campagne je pense qu'on n'a pas
de révolution on a quelques réformes et
la grande révolution à faire c'est la
révolution économique
comment fait-on baisser le chômage de
masse bien sûr modifiant droit du
travail et on pourra l'accompagner mais
en baissant drastiquement le coût du
travail
et là encore il faudra attendre puisque
le cic ne se transformera demain en
baisse de charges sur les salaires
ks co calendes grecques et c est donc je
ne vois pas les outils d'une baisse
importante en tout cas du chômage à
topeka ces belles c'est les chiffres et
par le premier ministre on va l'écouter
car ils l'expliquent du show marines up
de la baisse de la pression fiscale
ainsi la fiscalité elle est programmée
et il donne le chiffre veut d'abord
rassurer nos concitoyens
les contribuables ne seront pas la
variable d'ajustement du budget
les prélèvements obligatoires baisseront
de 20 milliards d'euros d'ici 2022
la france ne peut demeurer à la fois la
championne de la dépense publique est la
championne des impôts alors votre
réaction à cet argumentaire donc du
premier ministre sur il dit donc un
point point de pib d'ici 2022
non mais encore une fois pour ne pas
systématiquement opposée encore une fois
je partage le constat la france est à la
fois double championne du monde avec la
finlande pour les dépenses publiques et
en même temps en europe pour les
prélèvements obligatoires donc constat
juste mais il dit ensuite on va baisser
obtenir une baisse relative
je pense que c'est cela par rapport au
pib
un point des prélèvements obligatoires
ça veut dire que on va rien faire ça
veut dire que in attentes simplement
j'imagine que le pib augmente et que
mécaniquement si le pib augmente le
poids relatif par rapport aux impôts je
l'ait compris comme ça en tout cas va
finalement stagner ou baisser d'un point
pareil pour la dépense publique la
dépense publique vous dire là l'an
prochain nous serons nous atteindrons
avec la dette pratiquement 100 % de la
richesse nationale
c'est dramatique et on voit bien que ce
qui nous a proposé le premier ministre
c'est une augmentation de la dette
je peux pas les chiffres et je pense
qu'elle sera d'ici la fin du quinquennat
entre 250 milliards et 300 milliards
donc vous vous imaginez cette bombe
sociale qui risque d'éclater sous nos
pieds et est de mettre à mal je pense
qu'une le modèle social français sur la
dépense publique quand même il ya un
engagement fort que vous ne riez pas
vous à droite qui est de ramener cette
et en publie trois points en dessous de
ce qu'elle était en 2000
en 2010 est là et de ne pas dépenser
plus en 2018 qu'en 2017
qu'est ce qui manque au fond c'est le
mode d'emploi c'est quoi c'est à la fois
le mode d'emploi puisque on ne sait pas
comment on y parvient et on sait
d'autant moins comme on y parvient que
on a vu s'accumuler
une sorte de chapelet de mesures qui
vont coûter je parlais du service
militaire qui sera absolument inutile il
vaut 30 milliards d'euros
on a entendu 50 milliards
d'investissements dont une partie
consacrée à la formation la formation
c'est la dépense de fonctionnement et en
plus le système de formation
professionnelle du président de région
je peux vous en parler c'est pas en
additionnant l'argent sans réformer le
système qu'on parviendra quelque chose
on a entendu les prisons bien sûr il
faut des prisons supplémentaires
auxquels on a 40 ans du que une
succession une liste de courses et de
dépenses donc je suis incapable de vous
dire est bon que les échos dont la santé
par exemple on dit on va rembourser les
lunettes
je porte des lunettes très bien bon je
porte pas encore la période et à
rembourser donc voyez sur tous ces
sujets ça n'est que de la dépense donc
c'est très bien de dire on va vous
désintoxiquer parce qu'il ya une
addiction à la dépense publique mais il
faut savoir comment parce qu'autant on
pouvait supporter que le président de la
république reste avec des propos très
généraux et généreux mais il faut que le
premier ministre soit les manants coin
bouille il ya une petite indication
donnée quand même par edouard philippe
qui est qu' aucun ministère ne sera
épargné est-ce que ça c'est de te veux
rien de nature à vous rassurer
non ça veut non non ça veut rien dire je
pense que ce qui peut me rassurer c'est
qu'à un moment donné il indiquait qu'il
y aura une sorte de révision des
missions je pense que si on veut
vraiment faire des économies c'est pas
seulement en passant des coups de rabot
sur tous les ministères il faut savoir
ce que l'on demande à l'état de faire et
ce qu'on lui demande d'arrêter de faire
je pense qu'il ya beaucoup beaucoup de
double enjeu on connaît quelques-uns en
région il ya des dizaines et les
dizaines de milliers il faut faire
attention entre les doubles en
collectivité et les doubles en état par
exemple mais il ya d'autres exemples est
ce que la revalorisation par exemple du
midi
mme keyes ou de l'allocation adulte
handicapé c'était quelque chose qui ne
fallait pas faire
si sur le minimum vieillesse si mais je
vais vous expliquer très haut vous êtes
d'accord pour ça je suis d'accord si ce
n'est que nous avions proposé nous
pendant la campagne d'aller bien au delà
pourquoi parce que on se contentait pas
de faire une réforme systémique
il souhaite faire une réforme notamment
avec la retraite à points très bien
d'ailleurs notre groupe y avons
travaillé et on est des soutiens de
cette proposition
simplement si vous ne reculez pas l'âge
de départ légal à la retraite à 65 ans
vous ne dégagez pas suffisamment de
ressources pour aider les petites
retraites et avec le minimum vieillesse
vous devez aider un demi million de
retraités 500 milles c'est déjà bien
mais avec ce que nous proposions nous
pour les retraites de moins de 1000
euros
c'était et des 4 millions de retraités
et il faut savoir que les retraités vont
être les premières victimes de
l'augmentation de la csg
donc ça sert à rien là encore voyez il
ya une sorte d'effet de vases
communicants qui n'est pas sain sigean
se dire il faut expliquer aux français
ce qui va se passer réellement alors
vous ne parlez pas d'une mesure qui
était prévu il met beaucoup et c'est non
mais la baisse de la taxe d'habitation
oui ok reporter également un oui à la
fin du quinquennat laguna était allé
c'était aller là vous n'appliquez pas
parce que finalement vous étiez contre
oui alors je vais vous dire pour des
majorités pas c'est que c'est
contradictoire puisque qu'est-ce qui
nous a dit il nous a dit les français
vont en bénéficier
très bien un plus quand même vu dans les
communes il y aura pas de problème
retrouveront la ressource
je comprends pas d'où va venir à ce
moment là la taxe d'habitation
si la taxe d'habitation le produit de la
taxe d'habitation est compensée pour les
communes
à ce moment là c'est que l'impôt si
c'est pas un impôt local
il vient d'un impôt national ou d'une
ressource nationale
donc qu'est-ce que vous voulez que je
vous dise d'autre finalement ce qui a
été apprécié à sion positive alors non
je pense que sur la taxe d'habitation ce
n'est pas clair du tout comme beaucoup
d'autres choses et il faudra trancher ce
que j'ai compris il encore pour les
français c'est qu'ils devront attendre
avant d'en bénéficier mais je pense que
ça atteint ce lien
citoyen parce que quand on est dans une
commune le fait d'avoir des services
publics ça coûte
et si demain tout est gratuit il y aura
un problème il a commencé de manière
assez inhabituelle edouard philippe par
des mesures propres à la santé publique
et notamment par deux grosses annonces
qui l'ont qui sont l'une de la
vaccination obligatoire pour les jeunes
enfants tous les vaccins vont désormais
être obligatoire et l'autre c'est
l'augmentation du prix du paquet de
cigarettes à 10 euros est ce que ces
deux mesures sur lesquelles vous êtes
près la lui accorder votre renommée
soutien oui oui oui ça n'est pas à la
hauteur de l'enjeu
l'enjeu pour la société et et surtout
pour la santé du futur c'est quoi alors
il en a reparlé un moment tour discours
c'est la prévention comment est ce qu'on
arrive à mieux prévenir la seule la
santé de demain c'est la prévention ça
voilà ça c'est la préfon soit là mais
s'il ne trouve pas le tabac et ce pour
équilibre comme il meurt par an sur ça
il ya la prévention c'est pas ça j'ai
indiqué que cette mesure tarifs
je pourrais parfaitement la la soutenir
en revanche on sait très bien que le
système souffre d'une embolie de
l'hôpital et qu'il faut totalement
rééquilibrer entre la médecine
hospitalière et la médecine de ville
le précédent gouvernement a été dans une
dérive du tout public et ce qui fait que
notre système est totalement bloqué la
généralisation du tiers payant est une
mauvaise chose y compris pour les
professionnels de la santé
ce sont des choses dont on n'a pas parlé
la télémédecine sur les déserts médicaux
je suis désolé on le pratique
on a fait nous en région par exemple des
des plans pour lutter contre les déserts
médicaux
la télémédecine bien sûr il faut
simplement une tarification des actes
pour les médecins mais il ya tant
d'autres choses à inventer
j'ai rien appris vous êtes en dié mieux
en fait je me sentais plus on ne croyait
pas autant de lait à l'influencé mieux
mais j'attendais plus précis plus
précise c'est la raison pour laquelle
j'ai beaucoup de mal à apporter un
jugement très très circonstancié parce
qu' il manque énormément de moyens de
parvenir aux objectifs qui ont été
énoncées pendant une heure et demie
voilà donc votre jeu
merci beaucoup jean-francis deuxième
partie de l'épreuve de vérité maintenant
avec michaël szames est public sénat qui
nous rejoint formé à saint michel mont
saint bruno retailleau % le psg vous
parler un petit peu du sénat est ce
qu'il va faire maintenant office de
contre pouvoir quand on vous entend
depuis tout à l'heure
non c'est pas le rôle du sénat c'est pas
du tout le rôle du sénat
le sénat c'est une institution qui ne
procède pas de l'élection présidentielle
je me faire comprendre
il ya un déséquilibre depuis le
changement de calendrier désormais les
élections législatives ont lieu dans la
foulée d'élections présidentielles et
donc elles ne sont qu'une réplique
sismique donc on a une assemblée
nationale on le voit bien qu est un
wagon accrocher le wagon législatif de
l'assemblée nationale accrochez de très
près à la locomotive de l'exécutif mais
la démocratie c'est pas seulement
suffrage universel la démocratie c'est
aussi la séparation des pouvoirs est
donc cette séparation des pouvoirs est
incarnée aujourd'hui par notre
institution
le sénat qui est à l'écart de ses
mouvements si aujourd'hui à du cycle
présidentiel dont l'enseigné l'assemblée
femme n'est plus la séparation du poumon
'non non pourquoi
parce que il ya ce qu'on appelle le fait
majoritaire qui était renforcée par le
quinquennat et l'inversion de l'agenda
est aujourd'hui cette séparation est
mieux assumée par le sénat donc vous
poser une question contre-pouvoir ou pas
je dis non le sénat doit rester la tête
froide
avec un peu de hauteur de distance et a
porté sur chaque texte une amélioration
parce que les textes qui nous viennent
souvent de l'assemblée sont parfois des
brouillons pas toujours mais parfois des
brouillons on a nous un rôle
améliorateur coop de la loi et ensuite
on cherchera pas s'opposer pour
s'opposer au gouvernement serait quoi
dans une forme d'opposition constructive
comme l'exigeait dans une opposition
intelligente on sera dans une opposition
intelligente mais vigilante
parce que depuis depuis finalement
l'élection de l'après du président de la
république
c'est tout juste si on doit pas
s'excuser d'être dans l'opposition mais
là encore qu'est ce que c'est que la
démocratie c'est quand même l'existence
d'une opposition pour la possibilité de
ma d'une alternance on doit pas laisser
le monopole de l'opposition
aux deux extrêmes extrême droite extrême
gauche est-ce que vous
imaginez peut-être que en marche puisse
faire son entrée au sénat
et quelles seraient les répercussions
pour vous parce que ça peut aussi
peut-être faire changer déjà fait court
on s'est déjà fait la grèce via un
groupe en marche mais le groupe en
marche
en réalité au sénat c'est un
démembrement du groupe du parti
socialiste ce ne sont que des gens venus
du parti socialiste c'est à 99.9 pour
vous ne craignez pas d'hémorragie chaud
au jour d'aujourd'hui je vous le redis
va y avoir ensuite il va y avoir des
élections sénatoriales c'est septembre
ça arrive toujours être humble est
toujours là être prudent quand il ya eu
une élection au suffrage universel
indirect aussi et donc on verra bien
j'avais ma réunion de groupe ce matin je
pense que il ya une cohérence et y ait
une cohésion entre nous qui fait que au
jour d'aujourd'hui on n'a pas connu ici
au sénat les soubresauts de l'assemblée
nationale tentation macron chez vous il
n'y a pas de tentation macron pour maman
mais il faudra attendre aussi l'élection
mais ce que j'espère voyez c'est que on
n'est pas une hégémonie
on voit bien que l'assemblée nationale
il ya une tentation hégémonique avec ce
qui s'est passé la semaine dernière sur
la questure etc
c'est du jamais vu dans l'histoire de
l'assemblée nationale il ya une
tentation hégémonique au niveau de
l'exécutif puisqu'il va y avoir le spoil
system c'est pas le système le président
de république va remplacer 250 à 300
haut fonctionnaire pour avoir des gens
des femmes et hommes à sa main très bien
bon il faudrait pas que le sénat soit
demain aussi à la mode pour marcher au
pas donc moi je veux bien marché dans le
sens de l'intérêt général mais
certainement pas marcher au pas à propos
des sénatoriales ont dit que jean paul
delevoye est déjà très actif ici pour
organiser un peu le scrutin indirect
vous l'avez dit
oui vous inquiète est ce qu'il ya des
manoeuvres en cours non non je n'ai
aucune inquiétude concernant jean paul
delevoye
ce sont les électeurs les grands
désigner des candidats magron
compatibles écoutez qui fait provenir de
votre camp la recomposition est en
marche au sénat peut-il face qui fasse
son casting très bien mais je doute que
les grands électeurs apprécient a la
même valeur si j'ose dire les candidats
internet comme certains députés ont pu
l'être je pense que vis-à-vis des
grandes idées convergent ce gros
lecteurs en tout cas et on juge sur
pièce je veux dire que les grands
électeurs ne se font pas intimider par
une étiquette beaucoup beaucoup moins
beaucoup beaucoup moins que pour les
élections législatives et qui sont
illustratifs on l'a bien vu
il y avait plein de candidats qui était
totalement inconnu tout de noir oui mais
c'était leur sens où vous remet en cause
leur mairie tous les qualifiés de
candidats internes est pas du tout
simplement
j'observe que il avait besoin sur leurs
affiches de faire figurer la photo des
manades macron pas comme si il était élu
par procuration eh bien je pense que ce
simplement ce que je vous dis c'est que
les grands électeurs sont souvent très
exigeant sur la personnalité l'ancrage
l'enracinement ce qu'il a fait ce qu'il
n'a pas fait mais de toute façon c'est
toujours le suffrage universel qui est
le seul juge
voilà il faut l'accepter alors vous
allez exercer vous l'avez dit une
opposition vigilante notamment sur les
questions fiscales on les a abordés il
ya également le big bang institutionnel
qui est annoncé par emmanuel macron hier
au congrès en les côtes est évoqué ce
projet majeur 8 et reste toutefois un
combat inachevé dans notre pays
je souhaite le mener avec vous
résolument je proposerai ainsi que le
parlement soit élu avec une dose de
proportionnelle pour que toutes les
sensibilités
ils soient justement représentés c'est à
cette même fin que nous limiterons le
cumul des mandats dans le temps pour les
parlementaires car il s'agit là de la
clé de voûte d'un renouvellement qui ne
se produira pas sous la pression et
l'exaspération citoyenne
mais deviendra le rythme normal de la
respiration démocratique
alors je vais commencer deux hommes ont
d'abord parlé de la proportionnelle est
ce que vous attendez de savoir à partir
de quelle dose
on va instaurer ces professionnels pour
en mesurer les conséquences
non moi je pense que la proportionnelle
en réalité c'est une fausse bonne idée
c'est une fausse bonne idée parce que ça
peut conduire à des assemblées
nationales absolument sans majorité
et à chaque fois qu'on a vu sous la
quatrième république
les assemblées nationales chambre des
députés sur la troisième qui n'avait pas
suffisamment de cohérence à chaque fois
il ya eu un problème pour la france
le gouverneur de représentativité c'est
peut-être aussi ce que les françaises
souhaitent et que je que je relance
aussi oui alors le problème avec les
modes de scrutin c'est con un scrutin
majoritaire il est efficace il va donner
une majorité au gouvernement pour
gouverner pour réformer la france et la
proportionnelle effectivement on va vers
beaucoup plus de représentativité le
problème c'est que la france est
terriblement divisés
et si demain vous aviez une assemblée
nationale finalement à l'image de ce
qu'a été le premier tour des
présidentielles où on avait finalement
quatre blocs sans compter une grande
part de français qu'ils soient s'étaient
abstenus ou avaient voté de façon très
très divers sur des extrêmes
eh bien vous auriez assemblée nationale
très fracturée j'ajoute que cumuler la
proportionnelle avec le non cumul des
mandats vous obtiendrez des députés vous
obtiendrez des députés totalement hors
sol ils seront même plus enraciné dans
une circonscription puisque on aura des
listes nationales présentées par les
partis donc ça c'est vraiment la toute
puissance des partis qui positionnons
sur des listes investi par leurs soins
qui positionne ont leur candidat que
vous êtes en train de dire que la
représentativité c'est l'instabilité
je pense que il faut se méfier et que
l'élection majoritaire permet à la fois
de choisir les français c'est ce que
vous nous dites ce soir jeudi que trop
de proportionnelle c'est dangereux il
faudra mesurer la dose pour savoir si
c'est dangereux ou pas alors il ya une
question de dose mais c'est au delà de
la question de d'autres je pense que on
créera avec en plus le
que nous demandent à une catégorie de
députés d'élus qui sera totalement
déracinés alors doré videmment il ya
aussi la réduction du nombre de
parlementaires
est ce que le sénat que vous représentez
par la force d'opposition votre à ce
texte comme l'a demandé le chef de
l'état hier je pense que sur la
réduction des parlementaires on peut
tout à fait aller dans le sens de cette
mesure
le candidat que j'ai soutenu avait fait
cette proposition
pendant l'élection présidentielle là
aussi c'est un package tout est une
question ah bah non non nous faut pas
nous dire c'est normal ça ne marche pas
comme ça c'est pas prendre ou à laisser
on a un droit d'amendement petit peu ce
que on a un droit d'amendement et
m'accroupir ah oui mais donnons sa
nounou non mais c'est pour çà d'elvis et
moi je veux le voir mais moi je ne suis
pas sûr le petit doigt sur la couture du
pantalon pour répondre au sourire que
nous adresse e mc ren sais pas c'est pas
le problème mon problème à moi c'est la
france et l'intérêt des français je
m'explique
là encore bien sûr je suis d'accord mais
il arrive un seuil par exemple sur les
sénateurs ou les territoires qui sont
pauvres en démographie c'est à dire les
territoires ruraux
la france périphérique ne serait plus
représenté donc il faut calculer le
seuil qui permet notamment au sénat mais
aussi pour les députés d'avoir quand
même
au moins un sénateur un représentant
parce que au-delà d'un seuil
vous avez plus de représentation des
territoires alors la france veut pas que
les grandes métropoles mondialisée c'est
en même temps des territoires c'est la
spécificité française par rapport
d'ailleurs à nos partenaires européens
alors justement ce ballet theater va
falloir les re des coupures redécouper
la carte électorale est ce que pour vous
vous voyez derrière tout ça un acte
politiciens bien sûr qu'il y aura aussi
un acte politique en tout cas je ne veux
pas qualifier de politiciens pour
l'instant mais ce sera une opération de
très grande envergure
pourquoi parce que vos rayons d'exemple
ce qu'ils ont dit dans l'exemple des
députés vous avez 577 circonscriptions
admettons que vous ayez plus demain
qu'elle vous en avez un tiers en moins
400 et quelques il faut redéfinir ses
400 la plus une dose de proportionnelle
admettant 25% dose de proportionnelle
vous
vous avez là un redécoupage comme on n'a
jamais fait depuis très très très
longtemps et à chaque fois qu'il ya un
redécoupage
il ya des risques politiciens vous avez
raison de souligner si je résume vous
voterez au cas par cas les propositions
de loi qui est qui seront formulées bien
su mais en aucun cas un grand ensemble
de lois qui pourraient être proposées
genre de réformes institutionnelles qui
vous sera soumise non non non on a
commencé on avoir des discernements on a
donc à chaque fois nous la seule ligne
de conduite c'est ce que j'ai dit hier
au congrès c'est l'intérêt de la france
et l'intérêt je vais pouvoir de
contrainte et d'obliger le chef de
l'état convoqué un référendum
oui non mais on est dans une discussion
bras je vous voyez c'est pas du tout
qu'on oui j'ai bien vu il ya cette
menace lui dire durées fermes l'avait
sorti comme simplement non simplement
qu'est ce que souhaite le président de
république
il souhaite quel est le sens de cette
mesure il souhaite qu'il y ait moins de
parlementaires pour que ces
parlementaires
d'ailleurs c'était son expression soit
mieux équipés c'est à dire mieux
entourer qu'ils aient plus de moyens
donc il faut obtenir cet objectif et on
peut l'obtenir avec l'autre objectif qui
est de faire en sorte que les
territoires les moins denses les plus
ruraux puisse continuer à être
représentée par par un député par un
scénario paraît juste y est la loi sur
le non-cumul des mandats vous allez
devoir de choisir entre la présidence de
région et siège au sénat
elle vous fait votre choix france frais
mais encore quelques semaines le seul
bourreau non j'ai encore fait non j'ai
pas encore fait mon choix c'est un
joueur parce que c'est un dilemme
parce que c'est un dilemme terrible moi
j'ai toujours revendiqué cette idée et
je pourrais vous donner plein d'exemples
vous savez c'est parce que j'ai été
profondément enracinée en revendait
j'étais président du département
j'ai vécu par exemple drames de xynthia
le drame de l'erika le drame de l'erika
ça m'a permis de porter une loi c'est le
préjudice écologique
c'est pas un groupe écologiste qui a
fait signer c'est impressionnant mais je
sais mais c'est en essayant de tirer la
substance de ses racines qu'on arrive à
porter les préoccupations locales au
niveau national bien sûr je me
conformerai à la loi je vous rassure
et je viens seulement pour les gains
dans la nièvre au mois de septembre
voyagé jusque début octobre voilà vous
avez noté que le premier à annoncer la
fin des grands travaux 1 lors de son
discours de politique générale sans être
plus précis mais peut-être que vous avez
compris que notre dame des landes
l'aéroport pour lequel vous vous battez
ne verra jamais le jour
le premier alors le premier ministre et
en république ont voulu une médiation
avec trois médiateurs
donc j'imagine qu'ils font confiance
dans cette médiation et que n'ayant pas
donné une feuille de route toutes
écrites
moi j'ai émis des doutes puisqu'ils sont
nommés trois médiateurs et sur les 2 à 2
qui ont déjà pris position
d'une façon ou d'une autre contre notre
demeure donc donc non je pense que ça
n'est pas de mort je vous ai vu le poids
politique de nicolas hulot dit
simplement oui j'ai vu le poids
politique des cas alors je voudrais
simplement dire que en face du poids
politique de monsieur hulot
il ya une zad des indices qui sont en
contradiction avec les lois de la
république
voilà et je voudrais dire que le grand
ouest ces huit millions d'habitants
c'est l'autriche c'est la suède si le
grant west mérite pas un aéroport à la
hauteur de son développement
démographique et économique faut nous le
dire tout de suite voilà madame royal
avait été d'ailleurs assez simple à ses
cachets l'avait dit beaucoup t il donc à
prendre le tgv il dit on à paris
et ils iront prendre à paris bien sûr à
roissy ou à orly les avions à vous avez
toujours en rose récemment mais toujours
en restant chez moi je porte je peux si
vous voulez moi j'ai été élu président
de région pour porter les intérêts du
développement économique de ma région et
je simplement je veux rappeler qu'on a
eus 178 décision de justice qu'on a eu
un référendum à moi je veux bien que le
nouveau président républicain
écoutez moi le référendum je m'en fiche
moi 178 édition de justice je m'en fiche
je donne raison aux ultra violente c'est
à dire aux analystes
ça sera le signal que il enverrait donc
aux français si jamais on renoncer sur
ce projet merci michael troisième partie
de l'épreuve de vérité bruno retailleau
maintenant avec deborah claude notre
consoeur de l' agence france presse qui
nous rejoint pour sa question
l'épreuve de vérité avec life bonsoir
deborah bon sens michel bonsoir un bruno
retailleau de cession alors vous êtes un
des artisans de la défaite de la droite
française puisque vous étiez excusez moi
c'est un peu dur mais à proche de
françois fillon l'avait prêté beaucoup
de pouvoir fonder comment vous allez
dans votre famille politique refonder la
droite française comment vous
l'envisagez moi d'abord à un mot vous
dit vous êtes un des artisans je vous
dire bien sûr moi j'ai vécu cette
campagne présidentielle façon
douloureuse
j'étais un de ceux qui ont constaté
qu'il n'y avait pas de plan d parce
qu'il y avait des rivalités voilà et que
je suis pas de ceux qui quittent le
navire au milieu de la tempête
voilà je pense que la loyauté et la
fidélité la fidélité
maintenant je pense que sans doute la
responsabilité dans le sac contient un
échec il faut jamais le rejeter a priori
sur d'autres je suis parfaitement
d'accord sur cette analyse là simplement
la refondation de ma famille politique
je pense que elle passe d'abord par la
refondation des idées par leur fondation
en même temps d'un parti notre parti il
a toujours été très parisiens finalement
très centralisé et très personnalisé
c'est le culte du chef
bah ça c'est la droite mais je pense
qu'au jour d'aujourd'hui il nous faut
d'abord nous redéfinir quel idéal
voulant nous porter le général de gaulle
mails macron d'ailleurs a parlé à
plusieurs reprises d'humour réalité bien
sûr mais le général de gaulle avait une
phrase qui était plus belle encore il
disait la politique c'est l'action au
service d'un idéal à travers des
réalités
quel idéal la droite française quel
idéal la droite française peut-elle
porter comment est ce qu'on peut se
définir
il faut bien sûr des débats simplement
moi je suis partisan est ce que votre
corps est le même que celui de laurent
wauquiez
je vais vous dire je suis partisan de
repérer les crève en début d'année en
début d'année d'enjamber la fin de
l'année de repousser l'élection du
président de celui qui devra aller c'est
pour décembre et est prévu pour la fin
de l'année
tout simplement parce que je sais
parfaitement que si on part tout de
suite sur la querelle des ego chacun
voudra se distinguer par rapport à
l'autre ce sera encore une fois des
plaies qui vont se réouvrir sur des
plaies qui ne sont pas refermées
on a fait cette erreur en 2012 moi ce
que je propose c'est que on pose le jeu
on essaie de débattre on essaie d'aller
dans toutes les fédérations dans les
départements pour dire à nos
sympathisants pour dire à nos militants
qu'est ce que vous voulez vous quelle
est la ligne qui nous caractérise le
mieux en fasse un travail de
réorganisation sur le
fond et en même temps sur les idées et
ensuite dans un deuxième temps j'ajoute
on pourra procéder à une élection
est-ce qu'on est à quelques mois près
j'ajoute qu'il va y avoir vous avez
formulé absolument oui je l'ait déjà
formulé gelé déjà formulées et elle est
ce que je regarde autrement
bien sûr absolument mais ce que je
redoute le plus c'est qu'en plus en même
temps
l'élection sénatoriale soit prise en
otage évidemment puisque les élections
sénatoriales ça sera au moins de
septembre trois mois à bon compte trois
mois vent simplement les procédures et
les ego partiront bien avant évidemment
s'il ya une élection à l'automne ou au
mois de décembre
vous verrez très très rapide maintenant
il ya eu des défections puisqu'on à
xavier bertrand qui haïssent diable
celui qu'on n'aurait pas candidature n'a
pas tour ne compte laisser pas l'urgence
pour moi c'est pas d'urgence on a
quelques années sans élection on peut
très bien au mois de février par exemple
élire un nouveau président et essayer
avant de travailler au fond parce que
nos militants on les prend si j'ose dire
pour des machines à voter les français
en ont marre de toutes ces élections nos
militants ça fait depuis des mois et des
mois avec les primaires qu'on est dans
des séquences où on doit départager les
uns par rapport aux autres
peut-être qu on peut peut-être un moment
de un moment leur poser la question
qu'est ce que vous voulez que soit votre
partie de l'organisation
l'arrêt des hostilités par exemple entre
le nom de madame pécresse et monsieur
évoqué qu'est ce que vous leur dites
rester à nos les deux jeunes en jeu j'ai
pas un an mais je me situe pas comment
dirigeants sur les monts par ailleurs
alors non non non je dis simplement ce
que j'aimerais les états généraux de la
refondation
voilà se tourner d'abord vers nos
sympathisants vers nos militants pour
que ils nous disent ce qu'ils attendent
de nous pour qu'on travaille sur le fond
bernard acoyer a commencé avec un
certain nombre d'intellectuels a lancé
des pistes et je trouve que deux albums
saint-helier vous allez
ni deux j'ai un certain nombre de choses
mais en tout cas comment je pense que ça
commence
absolument ça commence demain donc c'est
une bonne initiative mais on a le temps
d'élire un chef
le culte du chef chez nous je sais que
c'est très prégnant mais on peut
peut-être s'en libérer pour quelques
mois en se disant on va s'attacher aux
idées à l'idéal qu'on veut porter devant
les français et qui caractérise la
droite sinon le risque c'est l'implosion
de la famille politique je vous propose
de confronter votre point de vue à celui
qu exprime alors peut-être quelqu'un qui
a déserté navire pour reprendre votre
expression c'est la sénatrice fabienne
keller qui s'exprime le temps là quand
ça lui est très divisée depuis
l'élection présidentielle les uns
reprochant aux autres
les chacun qui a été quand même terrible
présidentielle d'abord législatives
ensuite certains voudraient faire croire
que c'est la nomination d'edouard
philippe qui serait à l'origine de cette
difficulté
au contraire je pense que c'est notre
incapacité à gagner cette présidentielle
alors que en septembre dernier c'était
l'élection imperdable que nous devons
analyser pour mieux nous refonder et
réfléchir aux fondamentaux il ya donc
encore des choses à analyser sur l'échec
que françois fillon
non elle dit en disant il faut analyser
les fondamentaux finalement pas si
éloigné que cela débat parce que moi ce
que je redoute si vous voulez c'est le
choix il faut pas partir du choix que la
division est forcément meilleur il faut
pas qu'il faut pas partir du principe
que en étant le moins possible on est le
plus pur finalement je pense que la
politique ça consiste à additionner
plutôt qu'à soustraire je pense que la
politique finalement l'objet même de la
politique c'est de pouvoir créer un être
collectif à partir de personnes qui ont
des différences voilà il faut pas dix
quais même si je sais que c'est
difficile je sais que c'est difficile
c'est ce que fait manuel macron mais il
amalgame des gens qui ont des
différences il réussit là où il démontre
famille politique
le cas sera étudié au bureau politique
du 11 juillet elle pense que je pense
que justement un moment ou un autre il y
aura un prêt de cohérence je disais tout
à l'heure je voyais je voyais monsieur
collomb lire la déclaration de politique
générale mais il a voté toutes les lois
de monsieur hollande tous les budgets de
monsieur hollande le constat pourtant
était un réquisitoire assez dur sur
lequel était réservé quand même sur
l'orientation générale du nom me
reconnais c'est une personne de qualité
ça n'est pas ce que je vais dire mais il
y un moment où comment dirais-je cette
espèce de melting-pot va peut-être
craquelé quand il y aura des difficultés
parce que je pense qu'il ya des gens
comme qui sont assez différents ce que
vous êtes favorable ou fait qu' edouard
philippe ne soit plus membres de votre
parti politique à ce que thierry solère
dont vous parliez tout à l'heure je 15
heures de l'assemblée
je pense qu'il doit être exclu des
républicains je pensais on traitera
salle e
juillet je mise en position je
n'anticipe rien on va on va débattre
c'est simplement ce que je constate
c'est que emmanuel macron a évidemment
appelé edouard philippe au gouvernement
pour désarticuler la droite il l'a
reconnu d'ailleurs c'était être ensuite
sur une chaîne télévisuelle publique en
disant je veux maintenant déstabiliser
la droite bon voilà et c'est assez bien
réussi il doit pas marcher ça plutôt
marché la grotte nettement pas copain
exactement pas complètement que vous
pouvez avoir vu le l'observer donc on
peut pas dire quand même que ils nous
ont beaucoup aidés ils ont beaucoup aidé
leurs anciens amis dans un combat qui
était dur parce qu'effectivement il ya
vu la défaite présidentielle à la tête
de forces républicaines le parti de
françois fillon
qu'il y aura à la rentrée la traite de
ce parti pour l'instant là une assemblée
générale qui était purement technique on
à l'été pour réfléchir et ce sera à la
rentrée au mois d'octobre j'imagine que
lui-même et pas non non mais le il
souhaite se retirer
d'accord cette même se retirer un peu
près de la ville a annoncé oui oui quand
est ce que vous l'avez vu vous la
dernière fois ça fait plusieurs semaines
et je lis au téléphone récemment mais je
n'ai pas vu depuis plusieurs semaines
quand vous parlez c'est pour commenter
l'actualité politique est là pas votre
parti à la fois les premières semaines
les gouvernements macron peu peu en
commande que je pense que pour lui il
n'est pas dans le commentaire je pense
qu'il a souhaité tourner une page
c'était extrêmement douloureuse et quand
j'entends des prisons de république à
versailles au congrès à dire que la
présomption d'innocence est quelque
chose d'important
je voudrais y compris pour mes propres
amis qui considère que la présomption
d'innocence c'est quelque chose de
fondamental mais vous diriez que
françois fillon était en reconstruction
personnelle
bien sûr oui absolument bien sûr c'est
tellement violent c'est tellement
violent ça l'affecté lui s'attaque t sa
famille donc je n'en dirai pas plus mais
quel homme ne serait pas touché
profondément par un tel déchaînement de
violence souhaitent s'orienter vers le
privé a priori c'est ce qu'il est l'un
des six états lui de le dire c'est pas à
moi de les commenter
il ya une reconstruction qui est
compliqué qui est difficile et il
redoute les prochaines étapes
judiciaires donc bah écoutez il y en a
eu certaines pour ces enfants qui se
sont conclues plutôt positivement voilà
assez peu de choses qui ont filtré des
auditions
non c'est très bien et c'est trés
rapport simplement simplement campagne
savez moi j'ai pu être le témoin de ce
déchaînement médiatique et judiciaire
est gelée comparé à ce que je vis ce que
j'ai observé depuis il ya un quart du
gouvernement le premier gouvernement
d'émail macron qui n'a pas été reconduit
à cause des affaires ils sont à
l'assemblée est maintenant présent et si
certains de mes amis qui ont ils dans
tellement dure vis-à-vis de françois
fillon avait eu la même dans dur pour
des affaires similaires mais est-ce que
je commentaire c'est une observation
ça c'est la nuit vous re reproché à
certains de vos anciens amis politiques
d'avoir quitté la campagne à la fin
parce qu'il pensait que c'était perdu a
avoué ce qu'on vous reproche je rate
avoir été fidèle jusqu'au bout est ce
que vous le payez dans votre camp je
reproche rien à personne parce que la
violence a été telle
si vous voulez que je comprends les
attitudes des uns des autres ce que je
comprends pas c'est ceux qui ont une
dent dure quand il s'agit d'un tel et
une dans mol quand il s'agit d'un autre
voilà donc moi je n'accuse personne et
tu restes je trouve que vis-à-vis de moi
les uns les autres et y compris
d'ailleurs dans mon groupe on comprirent
de la loyauté et la fidélité
c'était des valeurs finalement dans la
vie mais c'était peut-être aussi des
valeurs en politique
voilà mais je pense encore une fois j'ai
eu souvent l'occasion m'ont expliqué qu'
on a traversé un moment difficile il
faut s'en remettre
il faut se redresser c'est par le débat
sénart le respect la bienveillance
convoi à chacun d'eux y avait
éventuellement en outre m
vous vous épauler mutuellement peut-être
alors avec françois fillon
non aux échanges
c'était une façon de s'épauler n'y a pas
de terreau atifi non non non non non non
non mais non non je n'ai pas vu depuis
plusieurs semaines et bien sûr gelé au
téléphone il ya quelques jours
première cabine question sans caméra
pour l'argent et le magot de forces
républicaines parce que c'est vrai clair
alors on va les l'argent de force
beaucoup sur et les dons et l'argent de
la primaire s'est tordu demande
instamment
donner cet argent alors et qu'est ce
qu'il en est mais moi je suis totalement
en millions d'euros
je suis totalement derrière la
proposition qu'a fait bernard acoyer de
nommer il a demandé à gilles carez qui
est un homme au dessus de tout soupçon
qui avait présidé la commission des
finances de lui mettre un rapport et ce
rapport ce sera un petit peu le juge de
paix d'accord ce sera larbitre et je
pense qu'il faut pas qu on est entre
nous de discussion d'argent histoire
d'argent il faut il faut objectiver les
choses et est très concret et rogue est
en jeu je veux moi plaidé dans ce sens
mais en attendant la nature à part merci
beaucoup d'abord merci qu'honorer
période avril mai avec nous aujourd'hui
à la semaine prochaine
[Musique]